[Musique]
oui
la journée entrepreneuriat étudiant
c'est une journée organisée par
l'université paris saclay est ouverte à
tous les étudiants et jeunes diplômés de
l'université paris saclay qui ont un
projet entrepreneurial
l'objectif c'est de les rassembler au
même endroit pour montrer la richesse et
la diversité de leurs projets auprès
d'investisseurs de starter de grands
mots qui sont là pour découvrir des
start up
mais selon ce qu'on demande à travers
cette journée les étudiants auront
l'occasion de présenter leurs projets
sous différentes formes
la première derrière moi c'est le salon
des étudiants entrepreneurs où chaque
étudiant à un stand où il peut exposer
son projet est super challenge et par
l'ensemble des visiteurs de l'événement
en parallèle il y à un concours de peach
ou chaque projet à trois minutes pour
essayer de convaincre un jury composé
d'entrepreneurs d'investisseurs de
grïngo et d'accompagnateurs à l'issue du
concours de bitche
chaque projet va gagner un chèque de 500
euros de l'université paris s'inquiète
pour les aider à continuer l'aventuré et
chaque président du jury a mis à
disposition des projets un cadeau donc
c'est du coworking de l'accompagnement
une rencontre qualifiée avec un business
angels ou encore à l'accompagnement dans
un câble
aujourd'hui on a différents types de
projets ça va du projet produit dans le
comme par exemple neospheres qui
a un outil pour les orthoprothésiste à
un produit pour les aquariums qui a
qu'au plan qui a un nouveau produit pour
la filtration d'un variable
la finalité de cette journée c'est pour
lancer des projets de se faire connaître
de rencontrer des partenaires de trouver
des structures d'accompagnement et aussi
de décoller grâce aux cadeaux de nos
présidents du jury ajourné
entrepreneuriat de l'université paris
saclay accueille 70 projets portés par
200 étudiants entrepreneurs et
accueillent aujourd'hui 500 visiteurs
[Musique]